six dr seuss books are removed from
circulation
liberals make excuses for newfangled
book burning and texas and mississippi
reopen i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get all the news in just
one moment first a reminder the word is
how people are abandoning their
overpriced wireless carriers and
flocking to pure talk for the same
coverage
but at a fraction of the price that's
right if you're with verizon a t or
t-mobile switching to pure talk could
save your family over 800
a year and switching is really easy you
can keep your phone keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and you're
thinking yourself well what if i go over
on that six gigs of data well here's the
thing if you go over
they're not going to charge you for it
so you have nothing to lose there's a
reason that puretalk is the highest
rated wireless company by consumer
affairs
stop giving your money to overpriced
wireless carriers and start saving money
right now from your cell phones i'll
pound 250 and say ben shapiro you will
save 50
off your first month that is pound 250
say
ben shapiro pure talk is simply smarter
wireless a lot of phone companies
intentionally try to confuse you when
you ask them to simplify what exactly
you are buying
they really can't well pure talk usa
will tell you exactly what you are
getting unlimited talk takes six gigs of
data for 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on that data they're not gonna
charge you head on over
to pound two five zero say ben shapiro
again dial palin palin250
and say ben shapiro you say 50 off your
first month at puretalk which is simply
smarter wireless alrighty so dr
seuss has now been canceled and don't
listen to all the idiots out there who
are saying
well you know he's not really canceled
you can still get some
dr seuss books right so they cancelled
like six
dr seuss books the the the arguments
that we are saying which we'll get to in
just a second in favor
of cancelling these doctors whose books
are asinine ridiculous
backwards and fully demonstrative of the
kind of values that the left would love
to cram down on your children
more importantly well not more
importantly just as importantly
they are fully demonstrative of the fact
that liberals have collap
have collapsed almost completely into
leftism see i always make the
distinction on the show between liberals
and leftists liberals are people who
disagree with me about taxes and about
abortion
and leftists are people who disagree
with me about all those things and want
to destroy individual rights in order to
pursue utopia
liberals don't have to be leftists in
fact liberals could just disagree with
me
about the extent to which government
ought to lend a helping hand and such
but what has been happening is that
liberals have decided that they are
going to collapse
full scale into leftism they're going to
go right along with utopian dreams of
the left
because as i've been saying before at
this point years the liberals have a
choice
they can either make common cause with
conservatism and stand up
for individual rights but their job
becomes a little bit harder in terms of
pursuing their policy goals because
conservatives oppose those policy goals
so
preserve the rights but you have to
fight a longer harder slog in order to
achieve your policy goals
or you can throw over the individual
rights move along with the left achieve
your policy goals but ditch the rights
and the left
and the liberals have decided it looks
like to make common cause
more often than not these days there are
a few old school liberals
who are objecting to the hardcore
canceled culture left
but not many not many and by the way
you know what what you're seeing is is
what the left likes to do which is water
now in terms like cancel culture to mean
anything
you see the sound the right too
sometimes people will use canceled
culture to apply to things that are not
in fact cancel culture
right but cancel culture does have a
meaning and that meaning is
that people go after you and your career
they look to destroy your life
based on a view that is relatively
mainstream
and or something that you did a long
time ago that is not controversial
right or at least isn't has not been
controversial for years right
resurfacing old tweets in order to go
after you
and going after your employment and
going after your individual rights
and unpersoning you right that is cancel
culture and we are watching it happen
full scale with dr seuss now
and you know people on the left are
doing this routine why do you even care
because
there are certain cultural indicators
that that show a society is in
a state of cultural collapse and this is
just a major cultural indicator it is
dr seuss is a major cultural figure in
america in fact dr seuss is according to
most estimates
the second highest earning dead person
in the united states it was michael
jackson
and then dr seuss dr seuss estate earned
some 33 million dollars last year from
the sale of his books he is the
best-selling children's author in
american history it is not particularly
close
and now you see the left coming after dr
seuss and cancelling
some of his books and when people say
well he has other books yes mark twain
had other books that is not a reason to
cancel huckleberry fan
you don't get to cancel things just
because you don't happen to like them
and again i'm wondering can you name a
person
a human who's been damaged by dr seuss
book
because i can hear millions of people
whose lives have been bettered by
doctors whose books
hundreds of millions of americans have
grown up on dr seuss books
can you name a single person who became
more racist as a result of reading a dr
seuss book
seriously can you name one the answer of
course is no but that doesn't matter
because we now operate
under a system in which if anyone even
claims offense
this means all of society has to change
and reflect their particular whims and
this goes back to the discussion we've
been having over the past few weeks of
expressive individualism we now are a
society that values your internal
feelings
to such an extent that if we refuse to
acknowledge the legitimacy
or justification of those feelings then
this means we are imposing on you
so if you feel a sense of discomfort and
one picture from a dr seuss book
the entire society has to cancel that dr
seuss book so as to make you feel better
because otherwise we are crimping your
style we're invading your individualism
and
after all that expressive individualism
is who you are it is a crime against
your identity
it's just the same kind of crime against
your identity as if somebody refused to
serve you because you're black at a
restaurant is if we don't cancel a dr
seuss book because
you feel sort of uncomfortable because
some people read a dr seuss book
this is where we have come as a society
and we've now gotten to the point
where we don't need government to cram
this down it's not a matter of
government this is a matter of an
intolerant
bizarre culture that has decided to buy
full scale into this definition of
atomistic individualism governing all of
society
that is what we have decided as a
society we are getting people to
preemptively cancel themselves
because that's actually what happened
here according to the ap six doctors
whose books including and to think i saw
it on mulberry street which was his
first
major work and if i ran the zoo which is
a great book okay i'm sorry but if i
round this it was a great book
and name the person who read if i ran
the zoo and came away thinking
well you know hate asian people now
because if i ran the zoo
has a picture of some asian people
carrying an exotic animal on their back
and gerald mcgrew young gerald mcgrew
riding on top of the
cage that holds the animal obviously
this is young white gerald magru making
those
asian people subservient no one has ever
honestly come by that opinion
no one okay the only way you come by
that opinion is if
some woke jackass decides that they're
going to make it an issue and then shame
you into believing that that's what that
page is about
i've read that book to my kids probably
a hundred times that has never once
occurred to me by the way it's never
occurred to anyone
except for this tiny group of male
contents who believe that culture
ought to be essentially made subservient
to their dumbass
over sensitive feelings it's ridiculous
so they're canceling and the thing i saw
it on mulberry street and if i ran the
zoo
they will stop being published at all
you cannot get them anymore they've made
them into samisdat
which is forbidden literature in the
soviet union right you're not allowed to
even get them anymore
i honestly i think that we should i'm
very rarely into uh the idea of
government regulation
but the idea of trademark and copyright
were provided specifically in order to
provide
so that nobody could take advantage of
your intellectual property
right you write a book nobody gets to
infringe upon your copyright until
a certain time has passed since your
death and
at that point then it becomes open to to
anyone
but the purpose of copyright was to
ensure that things are published because
why would you publish your work if
somebody could just copy it
copyright was not designed in order so
you could suppress material
copyright was not designed so that i
could buy up somebody's copyright and
then just kill it
so perhaps we have to rethink i mean
this is federal regulation
federal regulation right part of the
part of the constitution of the united
states involves patent and copyright
perhaps there ought to be a piece of
regulation that says that
if you take a a piece of literature off
the market
for more than two years then it becomes
public domain
because otherwise what you're going to
have is exactly what you're seeing right
here which is doctors whose enterprises
who own the intellectual property of dr
seuss
literally just taking the books off the
shelves if i ran the zoo was going for 1
500 a copy yesterday which makes it a
better investment than the us dollar
at this point it's it's absurd
and it is it is book burning i mean what
we are watching right now is book
burning
and you can call it whatever you want
but the only difference is that you're
not actively taking
a physical book and burning it because
all it takes now to cancel a book to
burn a book
is just a couple i.t guys in the delete
button and this is the danger of
digitization which we'll get to in just
one second first
let us talk about the fact that your
rights are certainly under assault right
now
if you believe in individual liberty one
of the best protectors of individual
liberty
of your rights is your ability to own a
firearm that is an ability that joe
biden would love to infringe upon
that's why now is probably one of the
better times to buy a rifle from my
friends over at bravo company
manufacturing
the people at bravo company mfg support
the right of responsible private
individuals to have the access and
ability to employ the same tools as
civilian law enforcement as a means of
defending ourselves
our loved ones our communities and our
freedoms should a threatening situation
ever arise
bcm assumes that when a rifle leaves
their shop it will be used in a life or
death situation by a responsible citizen
law enforcement officer or a soldier
overseas so quality is of utmost value
to them
every component of a bcm rifle is hand
assembled and tested by americans
as an american you've got the luxury of
living in a free society at least for
the moment
where you can improve your life through
education and religious exploration and
the open exchange of ideas
every american is responsible for
questioning debating confronting issues
if and when your life and liberty ever
come under threat firearms are first and
foremost a means to preserve the life
and liberty of ourselves and others this
is why the second amendment exists
to learn more about bravo company
manufacturing head on over to bravo
company mfg.com
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news
that's bravocompanymfge.com if you need
more convincing find out even more about
bcm and the awesome people who make
their product
at youtube.com bravo company usa
okay so dr seuss enterprises told the
associated press in a statement quote
these books portray people in ways that
are hurtful and wrong
these books were written in like 1940s
1950s
america the notion that you are deeply
offended
80 years later by something that was
drawn then we're not talking about in
der sturmer
we are not talking about in the local
kkk newspaper we are talking about a
children's book that have been read by
millions and millions of people and no
one
of serious mind has ever been offended
by this stuff i mean let's just be real
about this
the depiction of asian people in
and you think that i saw it on mulberry
street has offended precisely zero
people over the course of time it has
faux offended a lot of people because we
live in a society where you are granted
a sort of moral credibility by claiming
they are a member of a victimized
minority and in order to prove you're a
member of a victimized minority you have
to claim victimhood
but dr seuss has not victimized you and
children reading these books has not
victimized you obviously
but because digital book burning is so
easy all you have to do is hit that
delete button and boom the book is gone
buy hard copies of everything in the
future
the only people who are going to have
access to books are the orthodox jews
who bought them so they could read them
on sabbath to their kids
physical copies matter they're going to
do this with movies too if you think
that the digitization process which by
the way was the single
greatest i mean exponential explosion
of information availability to the
general public in human history
that has now been completely reversed
what we are now going to watch is
digitization which makes it incredibly
easy to disappear material
is going to become the the method by
which they just disappeared things you
will have bought a copy of dumbo from
amazon prime
like three years ago and one day you
will just go on to amazon prime and
it'll just be gone
it'll be as though you never bought it
it'll just be disappeared you'll have
bought a copy of ryan anderson's book on
your kindle it'll just be gone
as though it had never happened in the
first place digitization makes it super
easy
to disappear to sensing ideas which is
why you should always buy hard copies of
the things that you love by the dvd
of the movies you love because they
can't come in your house and grab it and
burn it at least
not yet but the bigger story here is
that you have a culture that pressures
creators into censoring their own works
and pressures
estates like doctors whose enterprises
into taking books down
into taking those books off the market
completely
doctors whose enterprises said ceasing
sales of these books is only part of our
commitment and our broader plan to
ensure
doctors whose enterprises catalog
represents and supports all communities
and families
they're also getting rid of
mcgillicutt's pool on beyond zebra
scrambled eggs super and the cats
quizzer
apparently they said dr seuss
enterprises listened and took feedback
from our audiences including teachers
academics and specialists in the field
as part of our review process okay first
of all that's your problem
don't pay any attention to the academics
and the specialists because they're
idiots
they're highly educated morons why you
just listen to the general public that
wants to buy it
and about whom there is no evidence that
a dr seuss book has ever turned them
racist
we worked with a panel of experts
including educators to review our
catalog of titles well
if the experts say so well then we know
that it must be true
the national education association
founded read across america day in 1998
and deliberately aligned it with t
with ted geisel's birthday right that's
dr seuss because yesterday was drew's
birthday my kids celebrated it at school
because they go to a non-crappy school
the nea founded the day on dr seuss's
birthday
and now they're busily canceling dr
seuss
for several years they've de-emphasized
dr seuss because he's bad you see
and encouraged a more diverse reading
list for children as my colleague matt
walsh has pointed out
basically we should just cancel
everybody who was not born over the
course of the last 10 years
because if you go 80 years ago there is
not a single human being in any living
human society who did not hold a view
you would find to be antithetical to
your own today not one
no one held the views you agree with
today no one
but apparently the nea thinks that we
should de-emphasize
dr seuss in 2018 a doctor's
museum in his hometown of springfield
removed a mural that included an asian
stereotype
because we can never have cartoons that
that are stereotypical about people in
any way
right you can't draw an asian stereotype
or a person
who looks black because like how are
cartoons supposed to work again aren't
all cartoon stereotypes
there's some that are significantly
worse than others you know namely the
ones with racist or
anti-semitic or bigoted intent but then
they're just cartoons
and if you look at virtually any cartoon
it looks like a stereotype like
literally all the cartoons
as producer elliot was pointing out
before the show moana looks like a
stereotype of hawaiian people
pocahontas looks like a stereotype of
native american people
in fact it is impossible to draw a
cartoon that does not look like a
stereotype in certain ways
because otherwise you wouldn't know that
cartoon from
you know a white person cartoon
so it sort of depends on what the
cartoon looks like and what the intent
of the cartoon was
and what people take away from the
cartoon and for the one thousandth time
you cannot name the individual who was
damaged by any of these dr seuss books
you cannot name them because they don't
exist the cat in the hat one of seuss's
most popular books has received
criticism too
but will be continued to be published
for now
for now and i'm sorry this is all
this is a cultural sickness that has
decided that all the hallmarks of
western culture ought to be
done away with and it is all the
hallmarks of western culture we're
canceling shakespeare
we are cancelling plato we are canceling
aristotle we are canceling dr
seuss like literally all the things that
western culture celebrates are now going
to be canceled because
they offend somebody you know jenn
sackey yesterday was deliberately asked
about dr
seuss being dropped from joe biden's
reading proclamation so joe biden put
out a reading proclamation
and in this reading proclamation for
read across america that he didn't
mention dr seuss
this was odd because president obama had
mentioned dr seuss like repeatedly
in 2015 for example barack obama put out
a statement saying the works of theodor
seuss geisel better known to us as dr
seuss have sparked a love for reading
and generations of students
his whimsical wordplay and curious
characters inspire children to dream big
and remind readers of all ages that a
person is a person
no matter how small that was his 2015
statement then again
2016 he put out a statement saying march
2nd
is also the birthday of one of america's
revered wordsmiths theodor seuss geisel
or dr
seuss used his incredible talents when
still in his most impressionable
reader's universal values we all hold
dear
through a prolific collection of stories
he made children see that reading is fun
and in the process he emphasized respect
for all pushed us to accept ourselves
for who we are
challenged preconceived notions and
encouraged trying new things and by
example taught us that we are limited by
nothing but the range of our aspirations
and the vibrancy of our imaginations
and for older lovers of literature he
reminded us not to take ourselves too
seriously
creating whacking wild characters and
envisioning creative and colorful places
but we have to take ourselves super
seriously which is why joe biden has now
participated in the cancellation of dr
seuss removed from the presidential
proclamation
speaking of which 2018 barack obama
direct quote everything you need to know
about politics you can learn from dr
seuss
but apparently he's bad now dr seuss is
bad
so here's shinseki responding to the
fact that doctors was left out of the
presidential proclamation
because essentially a bunch of woke
academic morons decided that dr
seuss's books were somehow spreading
racism and joe biden took that up
because the liberals have been so
intimidated by the woke left that they
refused to stand up even for iconic
authors
the proclamation was written by the
department of education and you could
certainly speak to them about more
specifics about the drafting of it but
read across america day which as you're
right has not existed forever has only
been around for
a short period of time elevates and
celebrates a love of reading
among our nation's youngest leaders and
the day is also a chance to celebrate
diverse authors whose work and lived
experience reflect the diversity of our
country and that's
certainly what they uh what they
attempted to do or hope to do
uh this year okay so meanwhile over at
uh
universal islands of adventure in in
florida
they are now talking about removing an
exhibit for if i ran the zoo
because it's no longer going to be
published so there's something called
seuss landing over at universal studios
we must not allow people to see the
the tufted mazurka right these fake
creatures that
zeus created we we definitely cannot
allow people to see
all the bizarre creatures from if i ran
the zoo because i don't know kids might
then go look at the book and they might
see a portrayal of an asian person that
looks stereotypical and then
they might i don't know go and hurt an
asian person all of this based on zero
on nothing also they're going to get rid
of a gift shop called mulberry street
store
which comes from and to think that i saw
it on mulberry street which was again
only his breakthrough book
now the defense is from the liberals
here are the part here that's that's
truly telling
okay because again up until five minutes
ago dr seuss was one of the
unconsolables
the fact is politically speaking dr
seuss was not on the right he was on the
left
i mean he was so uncancelable that
michelle obama was dancing with dr seuss
characters
like while she was well she was the
first lady of the united states here she
was dancing with doctors whose
characters look right there
next to her there's a picture of the cat
in the hat
and all the kids are wearing cat in the
hat outfits including you can see in the
front row some black kids wearing black
uh we're wearing
cat in the hat hats but i guess they
don't understand that they are
contributing to their own subjugation we
have to cancel cat and they have too
here's michelle obama just a few years
ago dancing with dr seuss characters
hi captain oh my god that's so racist
there's the cat in the hat
welcome to the white house you excited
to
hear this new wonderful book by dr seuss
yeah i can't believe she's participating
racial subjugation this morning before
he got on a helicopter
the president he'd love we love dr
seuss in our house
god this is so racist i mean first of
all they're i mean they're doing the
limbo i mean all of this is just
all of this is just racially insensitive
and all those black kids who are
celebrating dr seuss they're
all those kids are have just
internalized their white privilege
that's all that's happened here clearly
by the way just a quick note
the national education association which
is busily canceling dr seuss
some of their recommended books for
small children include i am jazz
in which children learn that they can be
members of the other sex right in which
a boy is treated as a girl
and this is considered a wonderful
wonderful thing and jacob's new dress
which encourages children to cross-dress
which is really really great
so we cannot have books from 1940 that
include
a stereo stereotypical cartoon of an
asian person but we can definitely be
encouraging our kids to read anti-racist
baby by ibra max candy which encourages
people to think in racist and racially
essentialist ways
and also we can encourage our three and
four-year-olds to cross-dress and or
choose their own gender
yes our society might be completely
effed it might be completely left and
it's the liberal defense of this that's
truly astonishing
again as i've been saying for a long
time here in the future of american
society the fate of american society
does not rest with conservatives
it rests with people in the middle it
rests with people in the middle who
might consider themselves
good-hearted liberals a people who might
be in favor of a little bit more
government interventionism or who don't
follow politics all that closely
are those people going to just go along
with the world crowd because the woke
crowd is the loudest
and the most annoying and the most
irritating or are they going to stand up
are they going to provide a
full-throated defense of individual
rights
the time for apathy is over here and
people
how could why are you making a big deal
out of dr seuss because you're taking
iconic figures and canceling them and
then you play this little gaslighting
mind game
where it's like how dare you pay
attention to us completely destroying
children's childhoods by suggesting that
they can change their gender and sex but
they can't read dr seuss
how dare you look into that why aren't
you more worried about other things
because that's the thing to worry about
okay i'm mostly worried about the kind
of country my kids grow up in
and how i and how i'm able to raise my
children
that is my chief concern in life as a
parent and you are trying to
reindoctrinate my kids into values you
hold dear by getting companies to cancel
books that i like reading to my kids
because you know better for my kid than
i do
and then you claim that i should not
feel imposed upon i should not
you are literally imposing on me by
banning me from doing things
and yet i should not feel imposed upon i
mean this is this is utter madness
and people mainstream liberals are
defending this of course
maine and we'll get to that in just one
second so let's take some examples of
mainstream liberals and their defenses
of this kind of stuff
ezra klein right the vaunted ezra klein
formerly of vox.com now of the new york
times because there's only failure
upward
in the world of the left-wing media so
ezra klein he tweeted out
uh an article from his old
publicationbox.com why fox news is
having a day-long meltdown over dr
seuss it says a lot about the modern gop
that biden and the democrats are about
to pass a 1.9 trillion dollar bill
with dozens of long-time liberal
policies and what's really generating
the heat on the right is some nonsense
about dr seuss
number one it ain't nonsense book
burning is not nonsense
canceling books is not nonsense that
what do you think is a more fundamental
value
i care deeply about the national debt
i've been railing against this garbage
1.9 trillion dollar bill that is
unsupportable by fact or economics
for as long as joe biden's been
proposing it and to make the brief case
against that 1.9 trillion
plan once again here's the case
according to the most liberal
institutions
the united states is going to experience
about a 450 billion gdp shortfall this
year due to covet the bill is 1.9
trillion dollars
so four times that that large that bill
also happens to include
barrels of pork barrels in barrels and
barrels of pork for the teachers unions
and for a variety of states that have
blown out their own spending there's a
study that came out yesterday from the
brookings institute a left-wing
institute that found that california did
not even lose tax revenue last year and
yet we are bailing them out with tens of
billions of dollars from federal tax
coffers
money that no longer exists and that we
are borrowing from the future okay so
there's your case against that now
which is more important to me bad public
policy when it comes to taxing and
spending which has been endemic to both
parties and has been the curse
of the american republic for as long as
i have been alive or the complete and
wholesale destruction of children's
innocence by a bunch of woke
who have decided that it is deeply
important to remove content that my kids
want to
see because maybe just maybe there will
be somebody woke enough to inform them
the content is racist what do you think
has more of an impact on my daily life
the spending that's been going on every
day and that is a problem and a
persistent problem and it shows no signs
of going away or the complete vitiation
of american culture particularly aimed
at children
i think we can tell so yes it's
important as recline and you know it's
important
that's why the left keeps doing it it's
unbelie the left plays this trick they
do something
utterly fringe and utterly crazy and the
right reacts and they go why are you
even it's a crazy thing why are you even
reacting to it
i mean sure what what do you even care
that we're saying that boys are girls
and girls are boys i mean there's a
budget problem
it's like well you know what's more
important that boys are not girls and
girls are not boys
and that has an impact on my life
because i don't trust you to let this
remain a fringe issue
because guess what five seconds ago you
were talking about
getting rid of books that you didn't
like that were actually racist and now
you're talking about just getting rid of
mainstream dr seuss books that have
never actually been interpreted by any
sentient human being as racist
and so you just found a bunch of experts
at college who have no actual jobs
to push the notion that this stuff has
to be removed from the public square
because he got ezra clients saying we
got bigger things to worry about then
you have mark harris okay so mark harris
is the is a writer and columnist for new
york magazine and vulture
and he and he tweeted out i read a lot
about theodore geisel dr seuss and his
politics
when i was working on five came back and
there's not a doubt in my mind he would
have thought all the people at fox news
suddenly taking him up as a cause
are the world's biggest a-holes well
there's no question dr seuss was on the
left on the political left
also he would not have thought that we
were the world's biggest a-holes who
thought we were the second biggest
a-holes
after people who think it's okay to burn
his books probably if i had to just make
a guess
and listen to mark harris's
justification for this geisel was a
fascinating and remarkably non-defensive
man who deplored racism
and was also capable of recognizing
where he himself had aired
so the blow hard right should stop
panicking there are still 39 zeus books
left the trump library will be fine
there are still 39 seuss books left well
guys i mean it's not a book burning if
there are other books
come on i mean that bonfire out there
where they're just burning copies
of books there are a lot of other books
i mean in germany when there are those
all those pictures of you know books
being burned is that a big deal there
are other books in germany everybody had
a copy of mineconf that was a book that
was in everybody's house
book burning isn't bad so long as it's
the right books you see according to
liberals so long as the right books are
getting burned
that is perfectly okay in fact it is
recommended and by the way dr seuss
wasn't fully cancelled we're only
burning some of his books sure the cat
on the hat might be nuts but
don't worry about the slippery slope
just recognize
that we're only going to we are only
going to burn the books today that we
want to burn today
and then if you ask them what books are
going to burn tomorrow like well we'll
have to see
yeah we know we know okay meanwhile you
have cnn's chris chili's remember these
are members of the press
who would have thought honest to god who
would have thought that the biggest
advocates
for restricting freedom of the press and
restricting freedom of speech in america
would be members of the press
who saw that one coming on their bingo
card on their woke idiotic left wing
bingo card who saw that one coming
because that's where we are okay where
we are right now
is that the press have decided they want
to see fox news and oann
and newsmax d platform they want to see
daily wire basically taken off of
facebook they want to see
social media crack down on anybody on
the right they'd love to see podcasts
taken down they want to go after joe
rogan they want to go after this podcast
and they want to go after all those
things because those are competition
members of the press
openly stumping for companies to remove
their service
abilities from people they disagree with
and now you have members of the press
who are openly arguing in favor of book
burning because that's what this is
when you take books down and you make
them unavailable anymore that is the
equivalent of book burning the purpose
of a book burning is to make the book
unavailable anymore because it has been
burned
okay so we are now engaged in digital
book burning so chris chiliza
the the doltish columnist over at cnn
he has a piece today titled why
republicans think dr seuss said mr
potato head
can save them he says
liberals are trying to cancel long
church cultural touchstones that is the
message for republicans solely because
it doesn't comport with their preferred
vision for america
yes that is in fact our our argument
that you're trying to cancel all the
cultural touchstones because you have a
utopian vision for what the world should
be
and anything that stands in your ways an
obstacle so you burn it correct
that is it that is a proper assessment
of our argument he says if you look
back at what has truly animated
conservatives in the months since trump
lost the election
it's consistently been less about policy
and far more about this idea that
democrats
are trying to rid the country of our
cultural icons
well i mean yes you literally spent the
summer
cheering on people burning down cities
nicole hannah jones author of the 1619
project cheered the fact
that these city burnings were being
called the 1619 riots
people were literally being iconoclastic
tearing down statues of george
washington
of abraham lincoln of a guy who's an
abolitionist
fighting for the north at like the
wisconsin state house
so yes we are worried about you
vitiating and destroying american
history
yes we are worried about all of that now
on tuesday morning says chris chalice at
cnn comes word that six doctors whose
books would no longer be published by
the company that owns them
because they quote portray people in
ways that are hurtful and wrong
what's remarkable about these attacks by
the right on so-called cancel culture is
that they don't even fit the description
so he says that the muppets right so the
muppets disney put a warning on some
episodes of the muppet show but they
made the episodes available
okay that's fair right that's not a full
cancellation that is just
a ridiculous attempt to contextualize
humor it's stupid but it's not a full
cancellation that's true
or potato head that's not a full
cancellation because mr potato head and
mrs potato head
will remain characters okay that too is
fair it's an idiotic thing to suggest
that
that children are are going to be deeply
harmed by a toy called mr potato heads
you have to call the overall toy potato
head
in honor of brian stelter but this is
the line that gets me
so chris chaliza says it's not cancelled
culture the muppets they're still
available
potato head that's not cancel culture
that's still available or dr
seuss while six of his books will no
longer be published the remaining three
dozen or so will still be on bookshelves
that isn't a cancellation
one of those things is not like the
others one of those things just doesn't
belong
so you've named three examples there
okay
two of those examples the thing didn't
go away in one of those examples the
thing went away
and you're still saying it's not
cancelled culture you're still saying it
wasn't cancelled
except that it was literally cancelled
and unavailable and selling for 1500
bucks on amazon
so what is chris chaliza's conclusion
what is happening in all three of these
most recent instances
is that the culture is changing changing
to incorporate more views from more
varied perspectives not just the
opinions
of what white people white people
the ultimate insults quiet people
you have to pronounce the h before the w
or doesn't sound right white people
and mostly men men with their
penises sometimes think is acceptable or
not
change is of course scary so do you see
this do you see this it's
unreal right so chris chili's argument
is that let me just read these two
sentences back to back okay
that conservatives have argued liberals
are trying to cancel long cherished
cultural touchstones
solely because it doesn't comport with
their preferred vision for america and
he says that's not true
that's not true because all that's
happening is the culture is changing
and it's changing to incorporate more
views
so you mean you like how the culture is
changing so it's okay to cancel things
so literally you are making my argument
for me crystallizing you're just calling
it change
by calling things change that doesn't
mean that the changes are good
or positive or decent or that book
burning became good today
i mean it's incredible so i'm arguing
that you guys are trying to cancel
cultural touchstones
because you want it to come you want the
world to comport with your perversive
vision
of expressive individualism and your
counselor argument is
well the world is changing so you're
wrong
no it is that you have a vision of
society i disagree with your vision of
society
i'm not trying to cancel you you are
trying to cancel everybody who you
disagree with
and all of their work change does not
equal cancel says chris julius except
when it does
except when the change literally
involves taking books off the shelves
and or pressuring companies to do the
same
then it does change and evolution in our
culture and our society is both
necessary and unstoppable
the idea we always have had everything
right or we can't always be growing
closer to a more perfect union is not
only narrow-minded but fundamentally
anti-american you see not to remove the
books
as anti-american now you see chris
chaliza
crystal elise is making the argument
that if you don't stand in favor of
digital book burning this means you are
anti-american
because change is american you see
do you see the ideological perversion
that is happening in front of you
should i be upset that there's an entire
wing of american society that now argues
that you can justify the basic violation
of individual liberty
and free speech and you can start
burning books because change is good
you know who has said that same thing
every fascist in human history has said
that same thing there has never been a
fascist who said
that he is doing something in order to
do a bad thing
no one ever believes they're doing
something in order to do a bad thing
this is why we have neutral principles
like individual rights
but he is saying well you know sometimes
change overrides individual rights and
to oppose that
would be fundamentally anti-american
chris chaliza unbelievable and then you
have that same
sentiment from philip bump over the
washington post his argument
is that if you oppose the cancellation
of if i ran the zoo this is because
you're a racist and you agree
with racism so his article's such a
giveaway philip bump again
this guy is the media columnist the
politics and media columnist over at the
washington post again members of the
press are super on board
with destroying everything they disagree
with they are the
they are the cheerleaders for
ideological authoritarianism here
here's what philip bump writes quote my
four-year-old son recently received some
books a family member had sent us a
thanksgiving present
yes recently but this is not a story
about the u.s postal service it is
instead
about the way in which stated concerns
about cancel culture can serve as
speckle
for frustrations over a changing world
this is the key word the chan
if you just keep saying change change
change right as in like barack obama
hope and change
if you just keep saying change over and
over and over that allows you to
override individual rights
if you just keep saying change over and
over and over that means you can burn
books isn't that exciting
so here's philip bump one of the books
he sent was dr seuss's if i ran the zoo
a book i had as a kid and that i
remembered fondly in it a young boy
imagines what he'd do with the local zoo
where he in charge
it's zeus so the boys conjurings are
wild weird creatures whose names rhyme
with their point of origin
okay so just know quickly that his
recollection of the book
is that it was charming that he
remembered it fondly
at no point here did he say yes that led
me down my path to becoming a white
nationalist and trying to murder asian
people
you notice he doesn't say that anywhere
because it's not true
right so he read this as a book as a boy
and then he wanted to read it to his
kids
and at no point did it occur to him that
the book was racist but
now he knows it's racist and that means
that his kid
will presumably come out a vicious
racist or not or maybe not
maybe this is all perfectly harmless
because you can't name the
harmless means not harmed right no one
can demonstrate a harm here
in a court of law in order to receive
some sort of settlement you have to
demonstrate
damages no one can demonstrate the
damages here because they don't exist
they didn't happen to philip bump but
he's afraid what is he afraid that if
his kid reads a dr seuss book that his
kid might come away a vicious racist
i sat down to read it with thomas and
rambled along in rhythm then i turned
the page to the african island of yurka
on which lived it on which lived the
tufted mazurka
in the zeus's drawing the bird thing is
perched on a pole being held by two
caricatures of african men that are so
obviously
and immediately racist that it was
almost breathtaking it would be like
watching an interview with tom hanks in
which she started
suddenly casually dropping racial slurs
a grotesque act
accentuated by astonishments at the
source this was dr seuss the benchmark
for authors of children's book and here
are the racist caricatures he drew
wow wow
if i ran the zoo as one of six zeus
books that will soon be out of
publication a decision made by seuss's
estate given it's obvious racist imagery
again racism doesn't require intent
anymore and it doesn't even require
effect anymore
it's just what you say is racist right
normally in order for a thing to be
racist
it has to either have a racist effect or
a racist intent
right it can be insensitive but for you
to call something racist requires either
intent or effect as a general rule
not so here philip bump who's never
affected by this book as a child now has
decided
that the book must be banned it must be
banned because he
was personally offended on behalf of
people he is not
this is just it's ridiculous so what is
his idea here the idea is that if you
defend
if i ran the zoo this means that you are
in favor of racism of course
the answer is that people who perceive
criticism of casual racism of the past
as criticism of their own behavior
or as a reminder of how the world around
them is changing
it's that zeus is a benchmark for a
particular sort of american upbringing
calling out seuss's infrequent racist
imagery is therefore an attack on that
view of american identity
it's a short hop from here to rhetoric
demanding we make america great again
so you're a trump voter if you don't
want these books burned
and again the basic idea here is that
you are a racist
unless you agree that dr seuss was a
racist and unless you are in favor of
the book burning
zeus's caricatures are hurtful
anachronisms are they hurtful really who
was heard
what's more until a few weeks ago my son
didn't know this book existed so where's
the harm and he's not seeing its images
oh boy oh boy what a case that is until
a few weeks ago my son didn't know this
book existed so what's the harm in him
never being educated
i could say the same about virtually all
aspects of information
i don't want my kids to be educated
about your crappy left-wing views
my kids have never been exposed to that
so why are you insisting they'd be
exposed to your crappy left-wing views
and in fact why is it your business what
my kids see or do
so you're libertarian when it comes to
you but you're but you're an
authoritarian when it comes to everybody
else
and you're and we're racists this is
this is what liberalism has become
okay in just a second we are going to
get to the book that predicted all of
this fahrenheit 451 which was right on
the money
ray bradbury was a prophet we'll get to
this in one second first
businesses have had to be flexible this
past year from working remotely to
pivoting their business models for
long-term survival and growth
if you're in charge of hiring for your
business these pivots have made your job
even more challenging especially
if you have to hire for brand new roles
thankfully there's one place you can
always count on to make hiring faster
and easier
ziprecruiter.com dailywire when you post
a job on zip recruiter it gets sent out
to over 100 top job boards with one
click
then ziprecruiter's powerful technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites these people to
apply it's no wonder that four out of
five employers who post unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within
the very first day see for yourself
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free
at zippercrew.com dailywire that is
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e let zip recruiter take
hiring
off your pa off your plate so you can
focus on growing your business
head on over to zippercareer.com daily
wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire go check them out
right now ziprecruiter.com
dailywire and make sure that you are
hiring only the best for your company
there's a reason we use
zip recruiter right here at daily wire
go to zip recruiters.com slash daily
wear right now
and let them show you how easily this is
done you can try zip recruiter for free
zip crew dot com
slash daily wire alrighty i had the
pleasure of discussing minimum wage on
my radio show this week with
representative rochana you know what
it is refreshing to have a regular
conversation outside of any forced safe
space especially in the current climate
every political issue is now hot button
issue everyone it's the same with
minimum wage now
minimum wage has historically had all
sorts of controversies and fallacies
surrounding it
the left makes the emotional appeal by
saying that well you know you're just
making people's wages higher well there
are also
all sorts of unintended side effects i
break down the myth
of the minimum wage and others like it
on my new daily wire series
debunked every single friday we are
dropping a new mini documentary last
week it was about minimum wage
this week it is teachers unions and
unions in the public sector more
generally
tune in to get the simple facts and
logic that debunk leftist claims on
these
and more issues to come all the
controversial issues we're going to deal
with them
week by week on debunked you're going to
have more material to
argue with your friends with have more
material to edify yourself or maybe to
have your mind changed
debunked is available exclusively to
daily wire members so head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunked to get
25 off your new membership that is code
debunked you're listening to the largest
fastest growing podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
so here is the thing all of this is
perfectly predictable because
authoritarians
always are predictable and if you read
fahrenheit 451 right now
they're a bunch of dystopian novels from
the 20th century that people like to to
make comparisons to 1984 comes up a lot
brave new world is obviously quite
prophetic and and how modern society
treats pleasure
and hedonism and sex and and how
governments use
such things to control people but
fahrenheit 451
has some sections that are just
absolutely prophetic i'm going to read
you
one of those sections from fahrenheit
451 a book that i'm sure will be burned
at some point in the future
for being insufficiently woke here is
what ray bradbury writes he is writing
in the voice
of captain beatty who is sort of the
villain of the peas
captain bd is the is one of the
firefighters for those who don't
remember fahrenheit 451 the book is
about
how there are firefighters the
firefighters no longer fight fighters
they actually start fires they go to
houses and they burn books that is their
job
okay so captain bd is explaining how it
came to be that firefighters instead of
saving houses
ended up burning books and how society
went along with it here's what he says
now let's take up the minorities in our
civilization shall we bigger the
population the more minorities
the bigger your market montog the less
you handle controversy remember that
all the minor minor minorities with
their navals to be kept clean authors
full of evil thoughts lock up your
typewriters they did
magazines became a nice blend of vanilla
tapioca books so the damn snobbish
critics said we're dishwater
no wonder books stopped telling the
critic said but the public knowing what
it wanted
spinning happily let the comic book
survive and the three-dimensional sex
magazines of course
there you have it montag didn't come
from the government down there's no
dictum
no declaration no censorship to start
with no technology
mass exploitation and minority pressure
carried the trick thank god
that sound familiar that sound familiar
it can have a
vast minority of minorities by the way
most black people do not want if i ran
the zoo band and most asian people don't
want if i ran the zoo band it's a
it's a small coterie of
pseudo-intellectuals
who earn their stripes on college campus
by saying extreme things and receiving
attention for it
and get tenure for that mainstreaming
that through a bunch of
allied liberal press members and then
pushing that into the halls of
government
and they changed the culture that way
and it is easier for corporations to go
along
with this small few than it is to stand
up and just say no
like dr seuss enterprises doesn't want
controversy so they figure is okay so
we'll take the short term hit they're
not going after cat in the hat after all
but here's the thing they will go after
cat may have as we know
and here's the and what's again the
thing that is most amazing about all of
this to me
is that when you protest that children's
innocence is being ruined
that the left has made an overt attempt
to change how you raise your children
to censor what you can show your
children on the one hand and cram down
what you must show your children on the
other
then the left side and you notice this
if you say anything about it then the
left says
why are you even paying attention to
children's books and children's
literature why are you even paying
attention to that stuff that's baby
stuff
yes we know that's why you're targeting
it there's a reason you are taking the
time to go after dr seuss there's a
reason you are taking the time
to push i am jazz to small school
children there is a reason
that you are taking the time to reorient
how small children are taught in the
united states and what sort of materials
they're exposed to it's because you know
that that is how you reshape a society
and if parents don't stand up
then it will just continue again
i would at this point overtly call on
congress to pass legislation
that ends trademarking copyright
protection for people who deliberately
bury material
if you have copyright and trademark and
your entire goal is to never let
literature see the light of day you
should not have copyrighted trademark
over that material it should immediately
be put into the public domain if dr
seuss enterprises doesn't want if i ran
the zoo to be out there it should be
public domain
because people have a right to see ideas
the whole point of trademarking
copyright was to
promote people's idea to see those ideas
again the goal of trademarking copyright
was to prevent people from copying those
ideas and putting them out there to
remove the profit
margin so that people wouldn't want to
put out those ideas but if you're
deliberately suppressing material
then there ain't no profit margin to
worry about you're deliberately
suppressing material deliberate
suppression of material
should not be given government
exclusivity
that is something that congress should
move on like right away i would love to
see republicans move on that because
censorship is a bad thing
it is a bad thing and we all know that
it is a truly terrible thing but
we're gonna pretend that it's not
because so long as the right people are
being canceled cancel culture doesn't
exist that's just cultural change
it's just cultural change after all and
we know cultural change is good
unless it's coming from the right then
it's bad but if it's coming from the
left it's good and cultural change
justifies any
any and all invasions of those
individual rights because utopia
requires that individuals put their own
selfish interests
behind the interests of the community
and the interests of the community lie
in creating a space where expressive
individualism is respected but only from
the left
only from the left of course alrighty
meanwhile
the the covid controversies continue
the joe biden continues to to try to
prolong this pandemic i mean
there's no other way to put it i don't
mean like in practical terms he's trying
to
prolong the inability of people to get
vaccines although i will say that he has
been
not wildly competent and we keep talking
about how we are trenching out vaccines
and it's good
right he says that we'll have we'll have
a short enough vaccine for everyone by
the end of may but you know there's one
area where the federal government really
is in control and that is in the
creation
of federal mass inoculation sites right
by the end of february he had a goal his
goal
was to set up 100 new federally operated
max vaccination sites
as according to the ap that was by the
end of february how many are up and
running because now it's march
seven seven it's a slow clap
for the biden administration on that one
right the vaccines are important
you might have wanted to hurry up by
making sure that um you know more than
seven mass vaccination
sites on the federal level were actually
created especially given the fact that
states are
are churning out their inoculations at
wildly differential rates
if you're in florida much easier to get
a vaccine than if you are in new york
there are people who are flying to
florida just to get the vaccine
there's a reason that at this point i
believe a majority of seniors in florida
have been vaccinated
if i'm not mistaken okay well meanwhile
in new york
andrew cuomo is still the governor
anyway joe biden continues to promote
the idea that this pandemic is just
going to continue forever because the
longer the pandemic continues
the more political priorities he gets to
push so here he is saying
that you know he's asked when we're
going to get back to normal and he's
like you know
maybe next year next year are you
kidding how about now how about like
right now
hey here is joe biden i've been
cautioned
not to give an answer to that because we
don't know for sure
but my hope is by this time next year
we're going to be back to normal
before that my hope but again it depends
upon if people continue
continue to be smart
and understand that we still can have
significant losses
there's a lot we have to do yet you know
that
we still have so much to do maybe it'll
be next year maybe next year
or we could look at you know the actual
statistics
as to infections rates in the united
states and we can actually see
for example what that chart looks like
and what you can see is that the daily
new cases according to worldometers
as of march 2nd the daily new cases in
the united states
56 890. okay at its height in january
it was 300 000 a day so we are down to a
small fraction
of what the daily new cases were before
okay coronavirus deaths
have tailed off following the infections
of course
now people on the left keep claiming
ridiculously enough that this has to do
with social distancing and masking that
is nonsense it has nothing to do
with social distancing and masking those
have been in place in places like
california the entire time it never
stopped
florida people have been acting in a
consistent way since the summer
the reason this happened is because you
started to see saturation point this is
what marty mccary from johns hopkins
university was claiming in the wall
street journal and on the show
he said by april we're going to hit herd
immunity and the stats
are showing that we are coming closer
and closer to herd immunity
we also have vaccinations taking place
on a huge number of people in the
population
we are now up to something like 15
percent of people who've had at least
one dose
and by the way one dose does provide
significant protection it's not as
though the first dose of a physical
vaccine gives you 50
and then the second dose gives you 50
it's not like that the first dose gives
you like
85 to 90 percent and then the second
dose is a booster shot
same thing with the modernist shot and
now we have johnson and johnson rolling
off the lines we're doing over two
million inoculations a day
in this country this pandemic is ending
and the left cannot stand it they cannot
stand it they don't like it
you're getting the impression they don't
want it to end joe biden is out there
being like now is not the time to let
our guard down
apparently just just into next year gang
into next year
here is joe biden mumbling his way
through his preferred solution
there is light at the end of the tunnel
but we cannot let our guard down now or
assure that victory is inevitable
we can't assume that we must remain
vigilant
act fast and aggressively and look out
for one another
that's how we're going to get ahead of
this virus get our economy going again
and get back to our loved ones so thank
you and please
please it's not over yet okay he keeps
saying it's not over yet but what if
it's coming to an end
i mean he's still talking about next
year next year and his administration
keeps saying idiotic things like if you
get the vaccination you can't go back to
your regular life
nope you can i'm just gonna put that out
there
you can go back to your regular life the
vaccinations are extraordinarily
effective
again 99 reduction in death 95 reduction
in serious case
90 reduction by israeli studies in
transmissibility
and that's the protection provided to
you and we're talking about
the vast bulk of deaths in the united
states having occurred for people age 65
or over and a huge number having
occurred in nursing homes which at this
point
virtually everywhere across the country
have been inoculated in
in mass fashion and yet there is there's
an obvious interest in continuing to
prolong
the suffering here meanwhile in texas
greg abbott
said you know what we're done here you
know we're going to open up texas
if you have a business you want to open
it up at 100 go for it if you don't want
to go don't go
by the way this is called liberty gang
if you don't want to go
don't go you can still stay home you can
still wear a kn95
you can still do whatever you want to do
right if you're
if you're a business owner and you're
still concerned about covet breaking out
at your business because it's a small
business and
people are still in close proximity and
you think not enough people are
vaccinated you can still put a
restriction on the front of your store
saying that everybody has to wear a mask
that is very common where i live
in florida okay i live in a free state
there's still local businesses that do
this that is their prerogative but
letting people make their own decisions
used to be thought of as traditionally
american here's greg abbott the governor
of texas
i'm issuing a new executive order that
rescinds
most of the earlier executive orders
effective
next wednesday all businesses
of any type are allowed to open
100 percent that includes any type of
entity in texas also
i am ending the statewide mass
mandate personal vigilance
to follow the safe standards is still
needed to contain covet
it's just that now state mandates
are no longer needed okay so he's not
even saying take off the mask he's just
saying
i'm not going to try and punish you by
law or find you for not wearing a mask
which again those mandates were not
particularly effective you know it was
effective people using their own best
judgment you can see
that the masking rate followed the
increase in disease all over the country
people started masking up when they
thought that the disease was going to
get them and then when they thought the
disease was not going to get them they
stopped masking up
okay but you can start to see the creep
here the mission creep today a cnn
pundit suggested
that the lesson from kovid is that we
should all mask up every winter so as to
prevent flu
no my answer to that is no and you know
how long we're going to continue this
further the answer is not long not
nearly at all
ted fitzsimmons writing for nbc news the
governors of texas and mississippi both
announced on tuesday
they would be lifting their state's mass
mandates and rolling back many of their
covet 19 health mandates just one day
after the cdc warned against complacency
in the face
of emerging coronavirus variants right
this is the new bogeyman
is that they're going to be variants and
those are going to take over okay so
let's say there is a variant are we
still going to shut down the society
like for another year how long can we do
this
seriously how long can we do this are we
going to continue to do this
forever because i'm not seeing any
timeline on the horizon for you guys
you keep just pushing the timeline out
remember two weeks to slow the spread
and we're now a year in and now joe
biden is saying maybe another year
no the answer is no
shortly after greg abbott made his
announcement governor tate reeves
announced he would end mississippi's
statewide mass mandate effective
wednesday of this week
reeves tweeted our hospitalizations and
case numbers have plummeted the vaccine
is being rapidly distributed
it is time now remember the whole
purpose of
the covid social distancing and the
masking and all that the whole purpose
of the lockdowns was to prevent the
overwhelming of the hospitals
nowhere in america are the hospitals
threatened with overwhelm
nowhere in fact even the texas
regulations suggest that you can kick in
local mass mandates
if you get within 15 capacity in the
icus
except that nobody's close to that
that's not a problem there are actually
reports coming out yesterday there were
certain hospital administrators trying
to game the system
so as to artificially decrease the
number of icu bets so they could say
they were within 15 percent of capacity
and thus kicking the mass mandates
which is just unbelievable perversion
cdc director rochelle wolenski strongly
cautioned against those roll backs she
said
i'm really worried about the reports
more states are rolling back the exact
public health measures we have
recommended
to protect people from covenant 19. we
stands completely lose the hard-earned
ground
we have gained oh do do we really again
i would love some evidence that the
lockdowns were super effective in the
united states
any evidence at all bueller
bueller okay i'll tell you what was
effective protecting the nursing homes
and then telling people to use their
best judgment and that was kind of it
that as some of us had been saying from
literally the second month of the
pandemic as soon as it was clear
what this virus was so you know they're
going to continue to push this
and at this point it is fully political
i mean it used to be at the beginning i
didn't think this was political now
it has become obviously fully political
there's an amazing piece from miguel
cardona who's the new education
secretary talking about reopening
schools now the cdc recommendations for
school reopening suggest
96 of kids should not be in school right
now or at least they should be in a
hybrid program
over 50 of kids are in schools my kids
have been in school the entire year
literally the whole year you know what
nobody got seriously ill
nobody died there are no major outbreaks
it is perfectly doable
and in fact these six foot distancing
notions
there have been a wide variety of
scientists who said those six foot
distancing notions in classrooms are
nonsense
it has come up with out of out of thin
air it could be three feet it could be
15 feet
right it could be anything and one one
thing we do know is that if you are
in a small enclosed space for prolonged
periods of time with
people who are above the age of
essentially 15 then there's a better
shot that you get the thing but with
vaccinations and the fact that so many
people have already had it i mean like
tens of millions of americans have
already had it
we are looking at herd immunity in the
very near future if we have not already
hit it in certain places
in the united states nonetheless you
have the education secretary putting out
a piece explaining
how he's going to reopen the schools and
let me just give you his steps to
reopening the schools
he says we must continue to reopen
america's schools for in-person learning
as quickly and safely as possible safely
is code for
let me just sell out to the teachers
unions so here are his steps
the education secretary note the schools
in europe are open
the schools in israel have largely been
open the schools in the united states
in places like florida they never shot
here is here are his recommendations joe
biden's secretary of education remember
this isn't political it's all science
one a national summit on safe reopening
oh a summit
wow that's going to be amazing like
we'll get together and we'll jabber
sounds great maybe we should do it via
zoom that's a little unsafe
says secretary cardona we knew there was
no one-size-fits-all solution the
different districts know their schools
best and would adjust to local coven 19
data my approach with the nation schools
will be the same
so we're going to have you know a
problem solving solutions oriented
approach here's our plan first we'll
convene the experts
ah more experts who will these experts
be students teachers families community
organizations and school leadership
also the unions second we'll share best
practices
you know like the cdc has been doing
with their best practices saying no one
should ever go back to school
third we're gonna get to work right away
on the education department's cover 19
handbook
well well handbook that'll do it and
fourth we need better
data about how schools are operating
during the pandemics so a study
and then finally we need more money even
though we still have 50 billion
or something that is yet to be spent on
the schools they don't want these places
to reopen this is all politics at this
point we all know it's all politics at
this point
it's pretty incredible and meanwhile i
will just note that
my theory about andrew cuomo the reason
andrew cuomo is going down in flames
right now on the sexual harassment stuff
is because everybody secretly knows that
andrew cuomo should be going down on his
culvert policy stuff that he was not the
best governor in america he was in fact
the second worst governor in america
after phil murphy of new jersey
you know how i can make that statement
clearly because all i have to do is look
at the death permillion rate
number one new jersey number two new
york in fact i can do this ranking
pretty solidly and and i can say that
you know if we just gauge elderly
population
versus death per million rate that's a
pretty good metric for which governors
did well
andrew cuomo is a damned liar he shipped
covered positive patients back into
nursing homes undoubtedly that led to
more outbreaks
and more deaths just basic common sense
suggest so
but now they're going to outstanding
cuomo on the basis of all the sexual
harassment stuff which by the way is
like
nothing compared to killing old people
and then lying about it to to your own
legislature they're going to ask them
for that because they don't want to come
face to face with the reality
this is why you're starting to see the
dam break against the end of cuomo
you'll know the new york lawmakers voted
to remove
andrew cuomo's emergency powers on the
pandemic
according to the universe according to
united press
senate democratic leader andrea stewart
cousins and assembly speaker carl
heastie announced the legislature would
pass legislation to immediately strip
cuomo of the powers set to expire april
30th
they said a year into the pandemic and
as new yorkers received the vaccine the
temporary emergency power served their
purpose it's time
for them to be repealed okay notice
they're repealing his emergency powers
amidst the investigation into the
coveted cover-up and the sexual
harassment
allegations okay now is a convenient
time for them to remove cuomo's power
but we all
should recognize what's really happening
here is just everybody covering their
ass for the fact that they never should
have gone along
with the cuomo train in the first place
in fact trevor noah basically admitted
as much you know credit to trevor noah
here for
at least a little bit of a
self-reflection all those people who
praised cuomo
so highly last year those people rarely
don't look so smart now
delete the tapes delete tapes delete
them all
i mean it must be so embarrassing can
you imagine if you're one of those
people
just burn them i don't give a sh burn
them you call yourself a homosexual
and i i i agree with you i feel like i'm
a homosexual too
yeah i think um it's been really it
genuinely has been very inspiring
and and refreshing to see a leader like
cuomo
yeah so just remember the real reason
that cuomo is going down the real one is
because he was a crappy governor who
handled covet horribly and lied about it
and probably got old people killed
and um the reason they're gonna use is
uh this sexual harassment stuff that's
just a reason to knock him off
and then pretend that it wasn't about
the covey because it was about the
culvert then they were also wrong right
they didn't sexually harass anybody
but they went right along with him on
the coveted stuff so they would have to
uh you know
avoid all complicity in that all right
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show on today's episode michael
will be talking about neurotanzin being
spiked
for her omb nomination that episode is
available right this moment i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
heron makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
republicans torpedo one of president
biden's most radical nominees the u.s
navy says blm
is non-partisan and the white house
threatens to force doctors to perform
abortions check it out on the michael
knowles show